hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that just happened in the VR
Masters uh VR Chess Masters of 2023
Wesley Seoul versus Levon arunan it's a
brutal game Lavon is leading the
tournament by a full point going into
round six and Wesley would of course
enjoy uh grabbing a full point for him
as he does have the white pieces here so
let's see what what happens here very
exciting line of the nimzo Indian uh
Wesley opens with Pawn to D4 we have
Knight to F6 C for E6 Knights to C3 and
Levon goes for the nimzo Indian Bishop
to B4 we have Pawn to E3 uh castles and
the Wesley goes for Bishop to D3 The
Bishop's attack against the names of
Indian we have Pawn to C5 and now Knight
to F3 is still by far the most popular
here but we have a knight to E2 by
Wesley the second most popular line uh
we have Knight to C6 and now Wesley
castle spawn to D5 we have captures
captures and now A3 and this is where
the fun starts the bishop is attacked
the boss Levon does not go back with the
bishop he plays uh or captures them like
he plays Spawn to C4
and now Wesley plays Bishop captures on
H7 with check and there is one game
where King captures on H7 was played but
here we have Knight captures on H7 and
it is now as of move 10 already that we
have a completely new game so okay uh a
capture some B4 reclaiming material uh
Knight capture some B4 and now Pawn to
B3 trying to destroy Black's Sentra as
black did play the C4 move uh we have
Pawn to A5 B captures on c for D
captures and now Rook to B1 we have
rooked the A6 also A5 not just defending
the Knight but also clearing the path
for Rook to come to G6 or H6 imagine if
this row comes to H6 Queen comes to H4
uh the the white king might get even
checkmated uh so here Ponte E4 opening
up the dark Square Bishop to control H6
and now Rook the E8 with Pawn to D5 and
now Bishop to D7 uh Bishop to G4 looks
like a more active move but uh you
really only help white if you if you
give him F3 with Tempo then the E4 Pawn
is nicely defended you can move the
Knight it's uh everything's perfectly
fine so here Bishop to D7 uh we have
Queen to D2 and now Pawn to B5 for the
moment it's possible uh the Knight is on
B4 so white cannot uh capture that B5
Pawn just yet
uh and here we have Bishop to A3 uh
Queen to D4 is the move that white
should play but it's very very hard to
see why Bishop to A3 is what Wesley
played and now there is actually a way
for Lavon to win the game uh or or at
least get excellent winning chances but
he has to find the uh a very precise way
of how to do that so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best move for Lavon uh while I give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible line and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight to D3 uh you give up the B5 Pawn
but the Knight will be absolutely
incredible here and you are getting your
setup with Rook to H6 and uh Queen to H4
so Knight captures on B5 Rook to H6 and
not Knight beta D4 you have to bring the
Knight back to F3 to help out with the
defense of the H2 Pawn so Queen to H4
Knights to F3 you stop Checkmate but now
Queen captures on e4 and now okay the
Knight Anita is hanging you will defend
it or you will move it and then Queen
captures on D5 and we end this line with
black being up upon and not only that
black has two pass pawns and also the
spectacular Knight on D3 uh so black is
much much better here it's a very very
hard to save white will be able to
survive this so after Bishop day3 that
was definitely the best slavon had but
Levon goes for something else he goes
Knight to F6 uh Knight the G3 and now
Knight the G for a different way of
going after uh the the white king here
we have Bishop capture some B4 no longer
allowing Knight to D3 so Bishop captures
Pawn captures and now Rook captures on
B4 we have Knight captures on H2 so not
even bothering with Queen to H4 Knight
captures on H2 with King captures and
now Queen to H4 with check
uh we have King to G1 and now Rook the
H6 this is how Lavon breaks break breaks
through and now how are you stopping
Queen to HD trackmate well uh Rook F to
B1 and now comes Bishop to G4 Bishop to
G4 very tricky move because it covers
the EQ Square so if um you play
something weird like Knight cat or some
B5 uh there's the very tricky Queen H2
checking to F1 and now you sacrifice the
queen queen H1 check only move Knight
captures and Rook to H1 will be
Checkmate complements of the bishop and
G4 stopping the king from running away
to E2 so here after Bishop to G4 there's
really only one move that Wesley can
play and that is Queen captures on E6
and H6 he has to give up his Queen and
that's exactly what he does we can even
do it in slow motion uh let's go uh
Queen captures on H6 we have Queen
captures and not Knight captures on B5
luckily for Wesley uh he does have
excellent compensation for the queen he
has the pass d-pawn uh D4 Pawn is
protected and he does have two knights
and two rocks so basically a rook and
the Knight for a queen we have rooked
the C8 by Lavon and now come sorry not
be it Rook to see it by Lavon are
preparing to advance his past pawn and
now uh we have rugged back to B2
preparing to to stop the pawn and now uh
Levon should continue with Pawn to C3
another big Miss for LaVon in this game
uh he goes Rook to B8 but C3 is
extremely strong here
uh the problem is The Rook is attacked
and once you move the Rook uh there's
Queen to D2 he should look into a way to
give the queen back but because if you
capture it's just game over C captures
on D2 and there's just no defense The
Rook to C1 check is coming also the D1
square is covered by the uh Bishop so
you're gonna have to play something like
Knight to F1 and after Rook to C1 you
will have to play Knight to C3 give up
the rook and B1 and after Rook captures
you cannot even recapture because the
Knight now has to keep an eye on the D1
Square you're gonna have to play F3 uh
kick away the bishop let's say Bishop D7
King F2 and now you're just gonna win
that uh piece there Knight captures on
D1 Rook captures and uh of course you
are now completely winning you are now
up a full Rook white has two pawns for
The Rook but that's no compensation so
basically what you would have to do
after Queen Teddy do not accept the
queen you would have to play Rook B to
C1 and now the game continues but still
it's very very hard to to survive this
you will play Queen to D3 the Knight and
B5 is hanging and after the Knight moves
there's this very nasty Bishop to D1
move and this is how our Pawn advances
forward if if the Rook moves you will
play Rook to B8 and now if Rook the A3
going after the pawn you will block this
would Bishop the C2 so really
complicated position but it's a very
hard for
uh White uh to figure out how to how to
even go about this game uh objectively
black is winning here but in the actual
game it's a very very hard to to spot
the correct correct path so here Rook
the B8 instead of pushing the C3 Pawn we
have Knight to F1 now bringing the
Knight to E3 which pretty much solves
all of Wesley's problems uh Rook to B6
level now again wants to go for the
attack with Knight to E3 and queen to H5
the bishop still covers E2 and uh here
Levon is still hoping to get this
Checkmate in uh and uh of course if you
play some like Knight captures on C4
then Rook H6 and you can resign the game
however the respawn to D6 for Wesley the
Knight nicely defends the pawn and you
prevent Rook to H6 so here Bishop back
to D7 and now comes Knight to D5 and
this situation on the clock was uh
pretty equal here some 11 minutes for
Wesley 13 minutes for Levon but I think
Levon already
had enough of this game they still need
to make 10 more moves to reach time
control and if he wants to keep going if
he wants the play for the win he will
have to play Rook day 6 followed by
Queen to the queen to E5 and then try to
um somehow do something for example Rook
the b40 goes after the pawn queen to E5
he has to give up the pawn now Bishop
captures on B5 and uh here not a rook
capture some B5 but Rook to C5 even
stronger threatening Knight to E7 check
to win the queen so Rook captures on D6
and now rugby captures on B5 this is the
position you will get let's say queen
captures on e4 Knight to E3 and okay
it's still a a rook in the night for a
queen but it's uh black who is much
better here so that's how you should
play it however uh I guess Lavon just
had enough of this game he just didn't
wanna want to lose uh he played Rook
captures on B5 and here they traded down
uh pretty much everything wrote captures
Bishop capture some B5 Rook captures and
here Levon settled for a nice uh
repetition of moves Queen to D1 checking
H2 Queen to H5 checking the G1 and it
was in this position on move 35 that
Wesley and Lavon agreed to a draw as
there really is nothing more uh to be uh
to be done here you can't really push
for anything the past Pawn is too strong
and um well it's just uh just a really
really really wonderful game uh Levon
did a Miss uh maybe not two winning
chances the the second one that we've
shown here were C3 okay this is really
really complicated and it's like a
separate game in itself uh but uh you
know objectively those were the two
winning chances that that LeBron had
that one and here after Bishop day three
had you gone for this Knight to D3 idea
uh and then just you know Rook to H4 uh
rooked H6 Queen to H4 and so on which is
uh kind of uh he he did go for this just
uh without this particular color
maneuver as this would win him the the E
and D pawn and without that white is
really really much worse uh so yeah
extremely complicated game I have no
idea who prepared this for for who uh
but um you know it is after a three C
four is really a move you have to you
have to prepare to play against someone
like Wesley so I think it was Lavon who
uh who who who prepared um uh some nasty
surprises for wisely here because they
were pretty much equal on time for uh
throughout the entire game so it's hard
to say you know usually the player who
prepares well will have more time than
the other player but here okay 11 was
only up on time a little bit uh but yeah
very very nicely done and already a new
game after night captures an H7 could
have gone uh really in many directions
but you can just see how complicated the
the positions were as uh well Wesley
survived the Lebon uh didn't find the
two winning ideas uh but still what what
a wild game
uh and yeah this classical chess in case
some of you were wondering uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh Lavon retains uh the full lead by a
full point
um uh lead by a full point uh some of
the games are still uh going on but I
really wanted to show you this one a bit
because uh at first I saw okay it's a
draw but then I checked out the game I
said okay I mean I have to show this one
uh so I really hope you enjoyed this one
uh always play the names of Indian it's
it's absolutely a marvelous opening uh I
would like to thank Cyrus Veena here
Joyce Roseman Lars this Amanda uh Thomas
and Phil matthus for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day